local health leaders are praising our
decline in covet cases in southern
nevada but they are warning that the
pandemic not over yet christian casadas
joins us live from our newsroom tonight
with more on the message health leaders
want you to know as we all move forward
kristen that's right brian denise well
the message is simple they are asking
all residents to take advantage of the
tools that are available to protect
yourselves from covet 19. now we're
talking about the vaccine the booster
testing and of course the mask use now
this afternoon health leaders from the
southern nevada health district said
even though the mass mandate was lifted
last week by governor steve sisilak in
most public places the omicron variant
is still highly transmissible they say
about 70 percent of the population here
in southern nevada have started the
vaccination process but only 57 percent
have completed it as some testing sites
are closing they are encouraging all
residents to become familiar with the
other 175 testing locations all around
the valley and self-isolate if you test
positive for the virus
we need to start preparing how to
live with the virus and what that means
is things like
non-pharmaceutical interventions
using your own judgment
and then also robust testing is going to
be a a part of the strategy moving
forward
while they understand and respect the
fact that everyone has the choice of
getting vaccinated and wearing a mask
they are hoping people don't forget that
the pandemic is not over now they also
mentioned that if there is another spike
in cases implementing health
restrictions again would be a
possibility in the newsroom christian
casa is live local now